-I'm talking with the great
Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
Julia, thanks again
for doing my show.
You know, you're doing
a fundraiser tomorrow night
with a couple of
your "Seinfeld" pals.
Tell me about this
and how it came together.
-Okay. So...
[ Clears throat ]
A couple weeks ago now,
I did a fundraiser
for the Wisconsin Democratic
Party with the "Veep" cast.
-Yeah.
-And it went very well.
It was very, very successful.
And, so, I'm just
constantly racking my brain
about getting the message out
about voting
and raising funds
for the Democrats
and what's an effective way
to doing that.
I thought, "Oh, well,
let's get the 'Seinfeld'
group together, if I can."
It was very last-minute.
I mean, like, hyper last-minute.
-Yeah.
-And we thought, "Oh, let's do
a fundraiser for Texas."
Because Texas is on the verge
of turning blue.
I mean, sort of all the way
down the ballot,
not just congressional seats,
but also the state legislature.
And that's incredibly important.
-Really?
-Because if we're able to turn
the state legislature blue,
then we get a seat at the table
when it comes to redistricting.
And, you know, the Republicans
have been very, very crafty
in their gerrymandering,
which is not a cool thing to do,
and so it's important --
State legislature races
in addition, of course,
to the other races, are just
as important, just as critical.
So we thought,
let's raise funds for Texas,
'cause there's
a real opportunity here.
So that's what we're doing.
So, Larry David,
Jason Alexander, and myself.
-Wow.
-And Seth Meyers
is going to moderate.
And we're going to -- Each of us
is going to talk about --
We're going to
pick an episode --
We have picked an episode,
each of us,
to talk about sort of,
I don't know, the making of,
behind the scenes,
that kind of stuff.
It'll be really fun.
-That's going to be great.
Can you tell us
what episode you picked or no?
-Yes.
I picked "The soup Nazi."
And Jason Alexander picked
"The Marine Biologist."
And Larry David picked
"The Contest."
-[ Laughs ]
-So -- I know.
So, anyway
that'll be super fun.
And we're going to have
sort of "Seinfeld"
memorabilia stuff --
I got, like, a --
That we're going to raffle away
to people who sign up for this.
And you can go to
afundraiseraboutsomething.com
if you want to --
to join the party tomorrow.
-Yeah. And it's important
to encourage people
to talk about their voting plan,
is what you have been saying.
-Oh, yes.
-Why -- Their voting plan.
So it's not even like just --
Why is that important?
-Well...
getting people to vote
sometimes can be a heavy lift.
I think sometimes because
the voter-suppression effort
is such a strong one
that people feel disenfranchised
and feel as if their vote
doesn't matter.
But, of course, you and I
both know that's not the case.
The more people vote, the better
it is for our democracy.
And I do mean that, really.
I say that as a Democrat.
I say it -- I believe that.
And research shows us
that if you, for instance,
Jimmy, talked to three
of your friends
who may not be
that inclined to vote, right?
And you say,
"What's your voting plan?"
And they say,
"Well, I'm not sure."
And you can kind of sort of talk
them into casting their ballot.
You will have a very --
You have a very good shot
at getting them to vote.
So, in addition
to making your own plan,
asking people in your life
what their plan is,
is very effective.
-It sparks.
-So my plan --
Here's my ballot right here.
I'm going to fill this out,
and I'm voting early
and taking it in next week.
That's my plan.
-Ah!
-What's your plan?
-I've sent mine in.
I handed mine to a --
I went to the post office
here in the building.
I did it last week.
I filled out my ballot
with black ink, by the way.
Black ink.
-Good.
-Don't use a pencil.
Don't use colored ink.
Black ink.
I did it in the secret envelope.
I put the secret envelope
in the other envelope
so that through the windows,
you can see it.
And, in New York City, believe
it or not, you need a stamp.
Which, a lot of people
will probably be like,
"Are you kidding me?
I don't have a stamp."
It's all -- I feel bad.
I go like, "If there's
someone in their 80s,
how would you even understand
how to do this,
unless you have someone
in your family helping you?"
It's like,
"Wait. This envelope --"
So I did a video. It's online.
I show people how easy it is.
-Oh, good!
-You can do it. And I showed --
This is exactly how do you it.
You put this envelope
in this thing.
It's like -- It's possible.
It's good.
But someone needs
to talk you through it.
-Yeah.
Sometimes, you know --
'Cause each state has different
methods, et cetera, et cetera.
So it's important to decide
what your voting plan is
and then get it done.
And if you can early vote,
like you did
and like I'm going to do,
that's a very good thing, too.
'Cause voter turnout
is HUGE this year.
5 million people have already
voted in Texas. That's a lot.
-Have they always --
Texas is giant.
But, I mean, have they always
had a lot of voter turnout,
or is it just this year?
-No. No.
They're getting more people
to turn out this year.
And this year,
there are about 2. million more
eligible voters in Texas
since 2016.
So that's like --
That's like the population
of New Mexico inside of Texas.
So it's just -- it's just --
It's a real opportunity.
Let's put it that way.
-Well, I gotta say,
you have been --
You said that you were going to
do this and get people to vote.
And already,
we're seeing numbers go up.
So this is all because
of everyone's hard work.
But thank you for doing
all this hard work.
It's awesome what you are doing.
-Thank you.
-It's always great to see you.
Good luck with everything
at the "Fundraiser
About Something."
-Right.
FundraiserAboutSomething.com.
Or you can come to my social
and sign up.
And any amount.
You can give any amount.
-Yeah.
-Any amount.
-Love it.
Julia Louis-Dreyfus, everybody.
We'll be right back
with Patton Oswalt.
-Thank you.
-You're the best.
Come back whenever.
-Patton Oswalt!
Tell him I said hey.
-I will. Perfect.
-All right.
-Bye.
-Bye!